good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy
tuesday the is over
yes very very exciting i can't believe
it's only tuesday last night's
bachelor finale three hours like when i
was done it was like 11
15 and i was just like whoa yeah there
was a lot to unpack
of course that's what we're here to do
today in addition to just
brightening the lives of millions of
americans and a few
canadians and also keeping you abreast
of all the other news that you need to
know which spoiler alert not much
jackie i can't stress how important it
is to
constantly be kept abreast no it's so
important like you think it might not be
but it is speaking of breast i actually
have a surprise for you today
i have a surprise for you okay you go
first since you brought it up so this is
really for people on the youtube
because it's more of like a visual
present um okay
ready are you gonna show me your
sexy shirt under my jacket shirt oh my
god can we get a close-up wait turn your
shoulder give it
serve it to the to the camera
oh my god i forgot about sexy shirt and
how much it meant to me
during the queue that i experienced and
i know you were going to be feeling all
rdh but it's only tuesday so i thought i
would brighten your day a little bit
that's something that's like it's always
nice to get a little sexiness on
tuesdays at least wednesday we have hump
day but like tuesday
what's tuesday deserves love too tuesday
deserves love too
in the form of a cold shoulder but now
my surprise for you i brought your gift
oh right i got claudia gift while i was
away last weekend i was just in the gift
shop and i saw something that i was just
like
this is claudia in the gift it's nothing
crazy but i saw it and i thought of you
is it a sweatshirt no it's i wrapped it
in a sweatshirt
so fancy i wonder what it is it's big
oh this is so nice thank you so much i'm
sorry that i didn't like wrap it wrap it
turn a puzzle turn it over oh
it is okay first of all it is a 500
piece puzzle which is my you know like
soft spot and it is a piece of artwork
with lots of leaves that says
piece by piece but peace is spelled p a
p p e a c e p e a yeah no it's a puzzle
that's supposed to bring
inner peace because like the leaves are
very common so this is a really hard
puzzle
yeah so i think that this is so
thoughtful it's just a puzzle plus piece
which is you
a puzzle plus piece and you know more
often than not a puzzle
brings me peace right so and this one is
designed to bring you it's just
beautiful
i thought you would like it this is from
the mayflower the mayflower inn it was
shopping real housewives history right i
just thank you so much you're so welcome
i hope you enjoy it i do i love puzzles
and you know i bought so many puzzles at
the beginning of quarantine
and i've done all of them already and
like do you do puzzles twice i don't
know
oh i don't know what people do because i
don't even do puzzles once
that's crazy like you're missing out
especially because you're so smart like
you have that type of mind and also like
if you are ever like
at a nightclub and you drop your earring
on the floor you want jackie there to
find it like she has crazy eyes
so you actually would be so good at
puzzles and it might bring you peace
maybe we'll do it together maybe we'll
do it together no i really actually
think like you of all people i know you
hate games it's not a game
it's so relaxing doing one on your own
with like a coffee and like you leave it
on your table
no that does sound nice i actually think
you would like it do you want this one
no okay oh my god you don't like it no
of course i do but i want you to have a
puzzle yeah no i can get a puzzle i
actually have puzzles in my house i
think because i've been like
easy because like a hard puzzle can
actually like ruin your day okay i'll
start easy i'll think about it
thank you you're welcome when you told
me you got me a gift i um
tried to get you one i just like never
found myself in a store do you know what
i mean no and also it's like sometimes
you don't choose the gift the gift
chooses you like i didn't go in there
saying i need to get something for
claudia but something for claudia
found its way to me and actually in my
own way like i did get you a present
because i traveled near and far and i
found a hotel that i just know you're
going to like so like
i did the work for you thank you i
stayed at the hotel
for you you're so generous that's what i
do here that's what sisters do that's
what sisters do so i'm glad you like it
hopefully you could play with
do
i'm going to be very cautious about what
i say like puzzles do give me
march tie-dye vibes ooh
i think a lot of people can relate to
like certain things that they hoarded or
started to do at the beginning of
quarantine that like no longer bring
them joy it just reminds them of that
really dark time like when we were all
tie dyeing things and pretending we were
happy
yeah that but it's like a year ago today
you know the two weeks to flatten the
curve that actually wasn't that dark of
times like we were it was so novel
that it was kind of exciting it was like
two weeks off four months later six
months later
eight months later like those were the
hard times at least for me personally oh
100
i actually on my time hop i finally um
caught up to like you know the flatten
the curve and i guess i actually
remember like
people were i remember my friend margot
came over do you remember at the
beginning of quarantine i was like i'm
having a game night like should i cancel
and you were like yeah and i was like oh
my this [ __ ] is so dramatic and my
friends came over and my friend margo
who's like always very smart she's very
like
cautious she was like are you guys gonna
like get like canned food i'm like
what like hunkering down for like a
storm i'm like you're crazy
and i was literally like the last person
to go to the grocery store that by the
time
ben went for us like it was when you
know there was no toilet paper and we
were literally living off of like
hawaiian rolls that was all they had at
the grocery store
but in my um time up i finally got a
picture of like when my whole counter
was just like filled with like random
supplies
yeah and it actually brought me back to
like that part was fun that was like a
sleepover yeah it's like a snow day
yeah you know but then it turned into
something else
yeah a snow year so i tie-dye i mean i
feel bad
i feel bad for the thai guy yeah no
tie-dying will just like never not
make me like sash i i feel that but i
feel like we could bring back puzzles
that one
is so peaceful and puzzles actually
really did were one of the things that
like made me really excited like it was
like a nighttime activity in quarantine
yeah that and like whiplash yeah oh my
god those were the days
also for me it was like reading and
cooking
and like look how far i've come in the
last year like i thought when i was
cooking pasta at home i was like wow
chef
that's true i was like i'm such a chef
and now like i'm literally
cooking lemon chicken lemonade like
mashed
potatoes made of cauliflower by the way
that's so true because i remember at the
beginning of quarantine
we were both saying how like people who
were listening to us who like use their
kitchens actively like they thought we
were insane but i had literally never
used my stove
yeah um before quarantine and i was
actually making myself dinner last night
and i was like look at me
i'm not even in quarantine and i'm
making myself chicken no totally
yeah good times proud of us as well and
i wish i had a kindle
because now i'm like so hooked on my
kindle mm-hmm but i was really
anti-kindle
you were i was like i need to i was like
so carrie bradshaw i need like to feel
the book
and now it's like i can't hold a book it
hurts my wrist you know and the
the airiness of the kindle is just
unmatched no it's unmatched and i just
got this
lap thing from barnes noble where like
you stick your kindle in and you rest it
on your lap it's like a pillow and so
all i have to do is tap and it's like
and my wrists i mean the kindle couldn't
be lighter but now if i have to hold it
i'm like wow
also kendall needs to come out with like
a little you know when you have a selfie
stick you get like a little bluetooth
clicker
claude i said this oh like on the show
but it was before you were a kindle user
and i
so agree they just need a bluetooth
sometimes you're laying comfortably
like you're lying on your 100 yeah like
they make them for like selfie sticks
and stuff
it shouldn't be that hard they kindles
have wi-fi they should have bluetooth
they like
they do have bluetooth i think so maybe
someone makes one but it should be like
the if i mean it's amazon like
they could do that in their sleep yeah
no they literally could
so yeah that is our quarantine recap and
i just really look forward to the day
where we stopped talking about
coronavares you know and i'm getting
there
yeah i look forward to it as well you
know what else i'm looking forward to
thursday because we have a little merch
collection dropping on thursday
and i don't want to spoil too much
you'll see it tomorrow we'll wear it on
the show
but i would say that it is beautiful
stunning and smart you know i would say
that too
and you know me i can't resist like a
little sneak peek so
there's what like five or six items i
have one in my hand and i'm just gonna
give you like a brief
hoop okay
it's so cute i was wearing mine
yesterday and it's also so comfortable
um it's a different material than like
the last drop and i'm
so excited for you guys to see it
thursday it will be launching stay tuned
for all the deets
it's just a small beautiful stunning
collection i would say it's a capsule
collection
yes yes love a capsule so yes that'll be
thursday but starting tomorrow you'll
start to see some of the items
on the show on our instagram so make
sure you're following the morning toast
on instagram
yesterday i was just like on fire with
the instagram there was so much content
yeah it was really good
so little time so little time and also
while you're on a following spree follow
me at jackie outre
and uh theo pups without no job they've
been on hiatus though
their social media manager is kind of
slacking no well i
i was going really hard for the pups and
then they came to me and they were like
listen we need to take a break like
self-care
we just need to focus on ourselves right
now and we just can't be in the
spotlight and i said pups i hear you so
they felt like they were being exploited
yeah and it was just like every day a
picture like i'm always texting the moms
like send me pictures of the pubs and
the pups were like
we're tired no also like we can only
post so many pictures from our houses
and like we haven't left our houses in a
year you know you know what it actually
was that made me stop posting so much
from the pups like i take premium
pictures of bruno every single day it's
a passion of mine but i can't only post
pictures of bruno to pups so i have to
wait for a premium picture of theo
that's not in his bed so i'm so it's
like waiting for rain in this drought
amazing [ __ ] reference waiting for
you it's like waiting for a rain
in this drought so that's real any
teardrop comes down
and even margaret magnolia just like
doesn't send me like portrait mode
natural lighting photos like the ones i
take of bruce and so the standard for
pups is up here and no one's meeting it
therefore there's not nothing to post
oh okay well that's actually the truth
and i think i feel
really good getting the truth off my
chest i think that you should get back
to work on the pups account like i think
and i think you need to be taking
premium photos of theo outside but i
think that like you see theo every day
and like you take better pictures than
me like everyone knows that
i have maxed out on pictures i can take
of him in the studio if you look at the
boys we just got a new rug no but if you
look at the pups instagram like
they're all it's either in the studio or
theo in the back well because theo's
just like his mom
no but like theo works so hard he only
has time to be in the studio or at the
house and i think if you actually look
at those pictures
you get a real sense of who theo is and
his work ethic i i mean i do agree with
that
so he needs to work a little less hard
play more take more pics 100
100 um so we have a great show uh
what's on tonight one of the real i
think real housewives of dallas i have a
lot of catching up to do i caught up
yesterday and like
i'm such a supporter of real housewives
of dallas i really am but like my god it
was so bad
really yeah and like the drama is so
fake
like it's like the
it's frustrating when like a housewives
franchise has low ratings and it's so
good and like people just
aren't seeing that but i feel as though
like they deserve their ratings based on
what they're giving me like it's really
nice okay well i felt like up until this
point the season was pretty good but
i think i'm like three episodes behind
now so i had to catch up on two
okay i'm gonna catch up today we'll
recap tomorrow switching
gears a little bit back to real
housewives and today's show is going to
be a
different little structure we're not
going to save our bachelor recap for the
end because we know that's what you're
all here for
so we are going to start with the
bachelor recap so without further ado
let's get into the past five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode you're probably
wondering claudia why you you're glowing
like your the bags under your eyes are
gone you look so well rested
thanks to bowlin branch today's sponsor
no one wants to cut corners on what's
important and few things matter more
than good night's rest
so true bowlin branches signature sheets
feel so soft and light you'll forget
you're not actually sleeping on a cloud
and they're sustainably made for
uncompromising quality from field to
factory
they make the softest organic sheets at
bowling branch and they get better with
every wash
comfort isn't their only standard they
use 100
sustainable raw materials and as for the
as the first fair trade certified
manufacturer of linen
you can feel good about your bowling
brand sheets as they feel against your
skin
so i told everyone like maybe like three
months ago i totally refurbished my
my bed after spending basically an
entire year in it
i felt like i wanted a whole new lease
on life from my bed
and i heard amazing things actually of
course i found out about bowling branch
from rage parcell and i thought if it's
good enough for the parcel house it's
good enough for mine
and it has been a haven like me and ben
are sleeping like
logs i'm having the craziest dreams
because i'm just like in this rem cycle
that doesn't stop
no wonder theo can't get out of bed yeah
literally like and why would he with
bowl and branch
um and obviously we have a great little
code for you guys but the ones that we
are using are the signature hemmed
sheets
they're the best seller they're buttery
soft lightweight organic cotton in a
classic sateen weave
for sheets that get softer over time and
what i like most about them is that they
don't get like too hot or too cool
because i get like a warm
i get warm in my sleep um they are the
perfect year-round sheets for most
sleepers and they focus on quality over
quantity no inflated thread counts
because more isn't always better they
come in seven beautiful colors in all
sizes from twin beds up to california
king
you can experience the best sheets
you've ever felt at bowlandbranch.com
and get 15 off your first set of sheets
when you use the promo code toast at
checkout
that's bowlin branch b-o-l-l-a-n-d
branch dot com promo code toast like me
and my friend nikki we're always like
obsessed with our beds like we're we
sending
like what pillows do you have and i said
volume ranch and i gave her my code and
she's living her best life
amazing sign on sleep well yeah it's the
only thing that matters
okay bachelor recap should we start
should we recap the whole episode yeah
i mean the really only part worth
discussing was after the finals was the
last 30 minutes
of the three hours three hour special
but we'll take it from the top for those
of you who didn't watch
we actually asked yesterday do people
want us to continue recapping the
bachelor and or
award shows and most of you said no you
don't need to watch anymore
but some people said like i don't watch
but i just listen to your recaps which
is helpful so let's just recap the
episode
and then we'll talk about where we go
from here yes so the episode itself was
so boring like i could have died like
those two hours felt
like an eternity right and you feel like
you have to watch live because it's the
finale so like you're watching with
commercials and it's just
painful painful so many commercials and
then the actual contents was just as
boring as the commercials because it was
just like all like
just fine like it was all standard like
of course matt's family loved the girls
they're both great girls like whatever
the family feels more strongly about one
but i actually felt like both
girls made a really great impression and
the family felt really good about both
of them
which was then interesting that his mom
gave him this advice which i actually
think was just really good
parental advice yes but not on the
bachelor but you know
off brand for the bachelor and to be
honest like
i i've always felt like the one of the
core problems with the franchise is like
if they really want like a genuine
success rate it's very rare for someone
the bachelor they say it's weeks
whatever it's literally the whole thing
is a month like
it's really not a natural place to fall
in love it's such a short amount of time
i think the way that they force
engagements like with rachel lindsay's
season it really came to like a peak
colton had a problem with it like most
people and
a lot of the people that they cast on
the bachelor are very religious
so most religious people like are not
willing to get engaged unless it's like
the one you know right
so it's become like this hurdle and even
though i like i agreed with matt like
okay you're not ready to rush into a
proposal so maybe you don't go on the
show that rushes people into proposals
right i felt two ways about it one
obviously like you know what you signed
up for that's what everyone says but on
the other hand i was
like i kind of like that the bachelor
this show is slow
like pumping the brakes a little bit
because these rush engagements
aren't a joke they're not productive
like the and so
i on a personal level i liked the fact
that he was like let's end this in a
relationship they're both pretty young
like
there's literally no rush but for the
show it's like
you said the whole time your wife was
true that's what it is like it felt so
random like
your mom said one thing and now
everything you were thinking for the
months before and that's what chris
harrison was trying to say
even though he did come off like a
little rude like of course he's gonna
take his mom's advice his mom is like
his whole world and
literally every time his mom cried like
i cried i loved her and that was good
parental advice outside of the scope of
like this weird journey that they're on
um but it also sort of felt like like
his mom said one thing and like he
changed
the trajectory of the show where it sort
of felt like he was
waiting for some sort of
reason to not get engaged yeah and i
don't think it's a big deal but like we
just then spent so much of the episode
like matt just like
sitting in silence like thinking should
i get engaged or not and from an
entertainment perspective it was so
boring yeah he cancelled the dates like
so it's literally we're watching him
base around his room
rachel paints around his room michelle
pace around her room like it was just
boring boring boring right and then
given
the topics of conversation at after the
final rose we never even mentioned
the whole plot of the episode which was
about
him changing his mind on an engagement
so everything we watch like we
there's never even a conversation about
it and of the three hours i feel like
they probably spent like 15 to 20
minutes on like what we were really
looking for and i could have used just
way more
of that but then by the time we got to
rachel and matt's conversation which
we'll get into
it was filled with like mostly silence
so like i'm just from from a
and we'll get into like the deeper
topics but just from a purely
entertainment perspective for a show
that's
supposed to capture us for three hours i
felt bored for so long of it and like
that's where i like i'm like why am i
subjecting myself to the show
yeah it's entertainment it's supposed to
entertain me
yeah but you weren't entertained i was
not entertaining i will just say that
the setup that was meant for the
proposal
um sickening so sickening maybe the most
beautiful in bachelor history
maybe like they're all extremely
beautiful but this was like a very like
hallmark wintry fall
vibe they're all really beautiful except
at the last season for both clarendale
and the zac and tasha like it was not
the cutest no it was not the cutest but
they did a wonderful job i thought it
looked like a fairy tale
and then they had the horse john
carriage i agree at the end and so
from a production standpoint i really
enjoyed the visual i completely agree
um when he sent michelle home it was
like really awkward because she had like
just given him that gift
and what we found out afterwards which i
thought was so crazy was like michelle
was like really heartbroken like off
camera
and that wouldn't even like talk to her
usually any i would say once we have
like
six or eight people left anytime someone
leaves it's a big deal and there's a
long conversation they sit outside
yeah you talk about like it's not me
it's you i'm sorry
matt was just like peace no literally
we're done
goodbye it was so like harsh it was
harsh and so i thought maybe
there was just stuff we weren't seeing
or whatever but the stuff we were didn't
see is the fact that she wanted to have
that conversation and that he said no
yeah and i really did feel bad for her
because she was like still even getting
choked up on after the final rose and
she's a great girl and spoiler alert
she she will be one of the next
bachelorettes and i do think like she's
a great girl worthy of love she can
definitely carry a show
um i think matt struggled with that
sometimes like being the lead
and i think she'll be great but um
i don't know if i'm gonna watch but
she'll be good yeah we'll talk about the
bachelorette the upcoming
season um but the the breakup did seem
very abrupt especially because they had
a really good day and things were going
well
yeah so but it's just been so clear from
the beginning that like rachel is right
so it's like at what point are you just
gonna break up with her like are you
gonna let her get dressed for a proposal
which i actually really respect right i
think towards the end especially with
the bachelor when they let like both
girls come up like in their prom dresses
like
at some point it's just mean yeah i
agree with that yeah
um and i always like when like you know
he sends a girl home
and the the girl who won like doesn't
know that the other girl went home and
she's like nervous it's like oh you
don't have anything to be
nervous about like it's you right in
fact but like rachel really thought
because he cancelled
they never canceled the last date and
then she showed up and i really thought
she thought it wasn't gonna happen for
her it was like a [ __ ] ending like it
just made no sense
it was but then it was a happy ending
and yeah it wasn't well so like the
whole time like
in their own way like i have really felt
from the beginning that rachel and matt
like had the strongest connection and it
was like something you saw all along
and i was like watching it like happy
for them but like also like not
like knowing what was coming up next
yeah so let's dive into after the final
rows the first thing was
chris harrison was not there and i know
a lot of people are upset about a lot of
people are happy about it but at the end
of the day like based on the
conversations they had like
i don't think anyone could have done a
better job than emmanuel acho like he
was excellent he was excellent he did an
amazing job i can't imagine and thinking
about how
chris harrison would have handled the
situation i just don't think it would
have been as impactful even if he wasn't
a part of the controversy like even if
he had stayed out of the whole thing
i don't don't think you could really
grasp it if you're not
black yeah and i just don't think he
ever really goes that deep ever
i agree so i think it ultimately worked
out people were confused because he was
still doing the narrations like
it was confusing i thought why didn't
they just have like a manual voice over
it or even matt like
yeah and it's also like he said he's
he's stepping back from the bachelorette
like here he is like working doing
voiceovers and in the episode more than
he's ever been in any episode like he
was everywhere
i mean they couldn't i mean they could
have i guess edit him out of the episode
but they
chose early in the season to not edit
the season based on things that were
happening outside of the season that's
true
um but i thought that him narrating the
rest of the episode i think it actually
worked for cohesion and then it was like
nice that it wasn't him
at the after the final rose yeah it
couldn't have been him like it really
and i thought emmanuel was great even
though like his jacket was so tight
i could not stop staring at his arms i'm
like if that was me like i literally
wore a dress on my trip that i busted
out of like
i couldn't imagine that like in the back
like there wasn't some torn seams
i was just getting very distracted by it
not that that was the point but i was
just curious
if other people were distracted i
noticed it once and then i wasn't
distracted by it though got it okay when
he sat down like they did loosen up a
little bit but every time he stood i was
like oh my god he's
busting out of the jacket um so he
brought michelle out first
like whatever those conversations are
always boring but i did think it was
interesting that emanuel asked her
about the rachel scenario and i think
she gave like a very kind of um
like political answer because you live
in the house with these girls like
they're they probably are friends rachel
and michelle
yeah and so if michelle is saying like i
think that rachel has a good heart i
think that that's
important to know yeah and for me and
like ben was
ben watched like the last 30 minutes
with me and we both
at the same time were like like kind of
blown away by
emmanuel said something that was so
pertinent because i think that like
we throw the word like racism around and
those types of labels like stick forever
and he made it very clear like rachel i
don't think that you are
racist you're not saying you're a racist
person there's a difference between
being racist and being racially
insensitive and he made it a point
to refer to her as racially insensitive
multiple times which i think is an
important
distinction i agree i thought the same
thing so i just think
that's when when he said that i'm like
he's he was the man for the job like
rachel lindsay was totally right in
nominating him
because it was so it's so layered and
this is like what
people talk about now all the time like
cancel culture and everything
and i think he kind of picked it apart
very delicately and
at the end of the day i think he was
trying to be devil's advocate trying to
like have compassion for matt
and i think he at like did an excellent
job like i would give him a
five stars out of five yeah while also
asking questions that i think a lot of
us
have yeah and at the end of the day like
when we sat down with rachel and matt
like it was not at all what i expected i
was pretty sure that they had broken up
because
that's what we heard that's what we
heard and i just don't know how like any
couple like really gets through that
like it's
so awkward you know yes so he sat down
with matt first and he chronicled
the post filming journey where they were
in the honeymoon stage it was really
great
these things started to come up matt
said that he just sort of dismissed them
as like rumors
and then after rachel connell put out
her apology
they broke up that's what he said yeah
and basically he had said that
when when they were talking basically
like at first rachel like
really didn't understand why they were
so bad and i thought that the question
emanuel asked
rachel like okay you win this show you
get engaged to a black man
how many nights do you lie awake
thinking about these photos you know
they exist
um thinking they're gonna come back to
haunt you resurface and her answer which
was super honest was like
literally i didn't think about it once
because i did not think i was doing
anything wrong at the time
and i think that was kind of like
indicative of the entire thing here it's
like
she didn't she didn't actively you know
go to a party wanting to hurt an entire
community
it was just her ignorance that blinded
her from like the history of antebellum
parties
yeah so i thought that was a great
question but what he had basically said
was like rachel's
at first now it seems like she's really
committed to you know learning more but
at first when it came out like
she kind of refused to even within her
within her and matt's relationship
refused to like see it as a big deal
yeah and so i think that her reaction to
that in the conversations that ensued
after
were the reasons and i think those
things are obviously things that we
don't know
but how they led to breaking up over it
yeah and at the end of the day
i just especially the conversation
between rachel and matt like
i just felt really really sad because
like matt was like super angry and like
when he was when emmanuel was like you
want to have one last embrace and like
match us out there like
they were i just felt bad for really
everyone like it was so sad because at
the end of the day like
there is a love lost and i really did
feel like if this hadn't happened like i
do think that they could have been like
hardcore otp yeah i agree it's so sad
for both of them i think for matt he
went on this whole journey to have it
end like this
right i think that he must be just very
sad and i think for rachel who
calls him the love of his her life like
multiple times that she'll never feel
this way about someone else like
it's just really sad that's how i felt
watching the end of it
and it was tough it was tough
like it was a really it was just really
intense and everyone was like freaking
out over the silences
but that's how those conversations go
right and so
that's what happened like they could
have cut them out sure but like that's
what was happening
yeah no it was super intense and like i
think even at times like emanuel felt
really awkward
because like like nobody was saying
anything because nobody knew what to say
like of course i'm sure matt would love
to like you know be in love with rachel
again and like take her back
but it's so much more layered than that
yeah
so it was an interesting after the final
rose perhaps the most interesting we've
had in a while
um but at the end of the day i just left
like with this sadness
yeah then they tried to turn things
around by announcing the new
bachelorette
and we're both the bachelorettes
it is katie and michelle so i think uh
he's going first katie's going first
this was based on the spoiler that i
read which turned out to be true
the spoiler that i read was just katie
oh no the spoiler that i read which
sounds totally true is that katie is
going first
then they'll film paradise and then this
summer they'll fill michelle season
because
she didn't want to miss school because
she's committed to those campers
and we absolutely love to see that wow
so she said she wouldn't have done it if
she had to
take off oh my god i love her she's like
so not thursday no
it's so beautiful like that the cameras
are her priority i just
no i know a million girls would leave
the campers in the dust
for a chance yeah she actually have a
lot of respect for that yes
um but and then also that explains why
we have
two former bachelor hosts
caitlyn i'm assuming one will be for
katie season
and one will be for michelle season oh
that's interesting and that way it's not
like
it takes two women to do the job of one
man right because it really and
not even the job of a man the easiest
job ever to say this is the final rose
right
there's one rose left uh thank you
professor harrison um
but that does lead me to the future of
the franchise and my relationship with
the franchise and
there was one episode where i was really
like you know katie's my girl because
she like stood up against the bullies
that does not a bachelorette make and i
just like
i feel and i get this way every couple
of years like very fatigued by the
franchise
really feeling like they take advantage
of my time especially last night like
three hours like
there was 20 minutes of really good
content in there and that's all we
really needed to do they know how to not
they don't know how to be like it's a
finale it could be one hour with a one
hour special
how long are episodes of love island
an hour i think but they're on five
nights a week got it okay would you
rather yes
no no no no no um i was just curious
so i think as it stands like i really
feel like i've
outgrown the franchise and of course
maybe that'll change in a few years
but even though i like michelle i don't
live for katie so i definitely won't
watch katie season
and although i do like michelle like
she's very nice like and nice is boring
like give me claire crawley crazy
chaotic energy
like that's what makes t good tv so i'm
happy for her i wish them both
incredible luck i do feel as though i
will be sitting out
this franchise also it makes me such a
negative person like
i come on here i agree i agree what
about paradise
paradise is good but then it's like if i
don't know the people like yeah so i
think you'll be able to watch this
season of paradise you won't know like
katie's guys
um but then probably going forward i
agree i i just i think
i've aged out yeah and
i'm moving on and i got a bunch of dms
from people being like
it's literally like an addiction like i
quit the bachelor years ago and i've
never looked back
like yeah and i just wanna i want that
energy for the rest and you know what
norma kamali said like
the pandemic like we are slowly coming
out of it and we have so much to do in
the next so much catching up to do
i don't have time to spend two hours a
week watching the bachelorette when i
could be at the edge of a cliff
like norma said i should be yeah i agree
so
that's that on that yeah see a bachelor
see ya and one last thing um
the com when matt sat alone with
emmanuel just kind of talking about the
responsibility he felt
internally and then just like external
pressures of being the first bachelor i
thought
the way he kind of communicated that to
someone who might not understand what
it's like to be the first black bachelor
like myself
um i thought was really uh well done
you know because he feels this
responsibility like going into the homes
of millions of americans who might not
have had like a black men in their home
before but
have like these kind of built up
stereotypes and like imaginations like
what a black man is and i just thought
like he did a great job
representing himself his family the
franchise him and his
brother look so much alike it was crazy
yeah
crazy but neither one of them i really
saw looked like their mom
no but they do look so much alike it's
crazy like are they twins basil
no i don't think so no but it's just
like me and you you told me that a lot
of people were saying online that his
brother looked like colin kaepernick
which is
so true yes crazy crazy
um okay so that's about your recap
anything else you want to say
i just who knows if we'll ever be
speaking as a bachelor again right i
just want to say goodbye
and you know bye goodbye it might not be
a goodbye
it might be a see you later but it's
probably a goodbye
and i want to say thanks for the
memories i've made actually a lot of
really good friends
from watching the bachelor um but i've
also wasted a lot of my time and lost a
lot of brain cells
so i'm gonna lay the franchise to rest i
do feel as though
in its own way the bachelor like will be
coming to it like i just feel like it
can't go on forever and
for a while it felt like it was gonna go
on forever but it's kind of starting to
like self-implode
yeah and i do think like it might be the
end of the bachelor as well
yeah not now not now but sooner rather
sooner than we thought
yeah i think these next two seasons plus
paradises are going to be very
indicative for them yeah i think a lot
of people also feel the way that we do
like
me too we're now going to say our
goodbyes yes
goodbye goodbye goodbye okay
are you ready for our next story yeah
some happy bed bed news
ocean ocean la la kent gives birth to
daughter
ocean it's a wave of happiness for the
emmett family
a wave that's funny vanderpump rules
star lala ken and her fiance hollywood
producer randall emmett have welcomed
their first child together
a daughter named ocean the 30 year old
new mom captioned a photo of herself
cradling the newborn on monday
saying ocean kent emmett um
super happy for them obviously i kind of
loved their very nonchalant announcement
like no
major photo shoot just like la la
probably on randall's phone like right
when the baby came out
yeah um and i i actually love them as a
couple when you think of how far they've
come like
remember she was driving the white
ranger over and over and thought she was
like having sex with an nfl player who
was like
paying for her life and now they have a
baby together and it's like a nice life
i'm really happy for them
i'm really happy for them i really like
the name ocean it's not
i hadn't thought about what i was
expecting but i guess i wouldn't have
expected something so
um conventional conventional for her and
i think it's just a really
pretty name me too it is really pretty
it's just so crazy like how
sheena is about to have a baby britney's
about to have a baby like in the last
year
vanderpump rules has changed so much
yeah they're still not filming also
sassy just had a baby
there's just so many vander babies
there's so many vendor bumps
well the bumps are turning to babies
that's true but um
i do think they're like we've said this
a few times there is
an opportunity for a show there but so
many of the members have been you know
quote unquote cancelled that i don't
know like how we go
how that works yeah but like this group
of very famous friends are all having
babies like
it is an interesting concept for a show
yeah really cute i don't know if we'll
get it but
happy for randall and lala me too i feel
like she was pregnant for like a while
oh i feel like hers was shorter like it
just felt shorter because it was like
came
after i guess she was the second
announcement but before brittany
i don't know i feel like britney's been
pregnant for so long my favorite thing
is like when pregnant people acknowledge
that like other people feel like they've
been pregnant for so long and they're
like imagine how i feel 100
that's gonna be me yeah okay next up a
little royal news prince philip 99 was
released from the london hospital after
28 days
prince philip has been released from the
hospital as and is in good spirits a
royal source tells people
the duke of edinburgh has today been
discharged from king edward the seventh
hospital
and has returned to windsor castle
following treatment for an infection
and a successful procedure for a
pre-existing condition a buckingham
palace spokesperson
said on tuesday that royal healthcare
man just keeping corpses alive
yeah i mean the pictures of him leaving
the hospital truckers for prince philip
are here oh they
they are very strong the royal truckers
they they ride
they were at home ride or die hard um i
feel like it was a little um worrisome
there for a second he was in the
hospital for a while
and i'm glad to see that he's coming
home yeah it's also kind of crazy that
like he goes to a hospital like wouldn't
they have a hospital in the palace you
know
yeah it's certainly big enough but also
like hospital has all the latest and
greatest
of course and like if we learned
anything from joan rivers it's like if
you're having a procedure
do it in a hospital go to the hospital
yeah because if she was in a hospital
for her standard
endoscopy is that what's called throat
thing she would have been fine
yeah damn damn taken too soon somehow
somehow all conversations lead to joan
rivers being taken from us too soon yeah
because it's all you can think about
once you think about it when you think
about like
health yeah picture of health joan
rivers i agree
by the way i'm looking at the monitor
and the plant behind you looks so
stunning oh i don't think we really told
everyone who's watching on the youtube
we've had some like recent changes
we got a lot of comments on our
instagram that the carpet we used to
have like looked like a wee wee pad
and it did no and it's like we didn't
need comments on instagram to let us
know like we
knew it was dirty with our boot marks
theo and bruno have both peed on it
jackie one time trekked in some like
weird oil on her boot that like left
skin marks everywhere
yes also then like two weeks ago while
we were doing patreon that i dropped my
coffee
and that was really the last straw but
the thing is is that on the show you
can't really see the carpet at all
except under the table so like it
doesn't matter
yeah but then for the post show pics it
was like it was gross
and i would try and edit them like you
know in facebook
or remove the statement there was
nothing that could be done so we got a
new carpet
it's supposed to be like one of those
this is like for kids like meant to like
have paint spilled on it you know
yes so hopefully it's better and
brighter and then our new
plant is from one of our sponsors that
we did uh last week
sickening right it looks so good behind
you now i want a plant and it's been a
while since we had plenty vibes here in
our studio when we used to literally
exclusively cultivate plenty vibes in
our old studio right and this is a live
one those ones were fake oh we got to
take care of it
yeah water and everything we have a
living being
in the studio wow someone for someone's
living here squatter
it's a ghost spooky that goes to
bloomscape's path
um before we move on i do feel like i
have something to say
okay i think it's so important that when
you have something to say that you say
it
and i really feel like today's sponsor
speaks for itself and i don't know if
there's any toasters left who don't have
brushes
but just in case there is one lonely
toaster who hasn't gotten a bruce yet
i am here to change your life because
bruce is the best electric toothbrush
on the market it is so well designed
works so well and it is so
reasonably priced where so many um
electric toothbrushes cost over 200
which is why for the longest time i
never bothered to get one even though i
knew
that it would be better and then bruce
came into our lives and
changed us completely the brush itself
has six unique modes to customize your
brushing experience
the battery life lasts four weeks and it
comes with a magnetic charging stand and
compact
travel case they also have a
subscription program
so you never forget to change your brush
head again they'll ship you new
replacement heads every six months so
you're never stuck using a worn down
brush head
which as i recently learned can lead to
bad breath and just a lot of problems so
you got to change
your brush a lot and if you're using
plastic toothbrushes that is not good
for the environment another reason
to go bruce they have sleek designs the
brush electric toothbrush
has a modern aesthetically pleasing
design that comes in trend driven
seasonal colors and
it looks great on your bathroom counter
if you want to get 15 off your brush
toothbrush kit
and refill plan use the promo code toast
at bruce.com
that's 15 off using the code toast at
brush.com
and for that one lonely toaster who
hasn't gotten it yet don't wait
it's gonna change your life okay last
two stories are a little
tv news first up grammy's ratings tank
in 2021
possibly to an all-time low the 2021
grammars
made history and turned heads but it
still couldn't win the ratings game
early ratings from nielsen have the
awards drawing a measly 7.9
million total viewers although the
numbers should climb when
adjusted for time zones last year 18.7
million viewers
tuned into the event and that was also
pretty low
wait to go from 18 to eight
yeah and then in 2019 it was um
19.9 got it so to go from 19 to 18 it's
like whatever we're living in the age of
streaming of course it's going to go
down
but to go from 18 to 8 that's really bad
that's really bad and it's like i feel
like last night's episode of the
bachelor probably put up like this
close numbers because i think bachelor
usually gets around like 2 million but i
feel like
um i feel like everyone was watching
that after the final rose last night
wait i'm shocked like and by the way
it's really bad
we report on this after every award show
like the ratings always go down and it's
just like a combination of
people not having cable anymore kind of
celebrities like
especially in recent years especially
with kobe like just becoming like
random almost and i'm just like shocked
at the
the skip like i did i read that headline
but i did not read that first line like
that's [ __ ]
crazy yeah crazy and i'm actually really
shocked that it's the grammys because i
think of
and i said this yesterday of all the
award shows the grammys to me is like
the most inclusive in terms of like
i think the most people from different
walks of life like listen to music you
know
everyone listens to music and all genres
are represented
all age groups like i don't know i find
that shocking yeah i mean
people don't want it they don't want it
good too
good to know for us and after our
conversation yesterday um
we got a lot of feedback from people
saying they won't be watching the oscars
and they really don't need us to recap
it so
thank you because i'm gonna use those
few hours to take enormous advice and go
to the edge of a cliff
perfect looking forward to it i'll
probably just sit in bed like watching
something else but you know what i mean
maybe you'll be reading maybe i'll be
doing your puzzle
i've got to finish the mother-in-law
this book that i'm reading i just love
it like i don't want to finish it oh
that's so great
yeah i'm reading a book that i have been
read like it's taking me so long i'm not
really loving it but now i'm at like 80
so hopefully i can just finish it it's
called the editor and
i chose it is it called the big time
magazine editor or just just the editor
actually it is a big time editor because
it's like um
historical fantasy it's like the editor
is jackie oh like she
like edits for a publishing house so
it's like it's not real but it's based
on a real person that's so interesting
i thought so too yeah you know
um this and final story a little more tv
news world of dance was cancelled at nbc
after four seasons and before you ask it
is the one with
jlo oh okay well so there's so you think
you can dance which is like
the less popular dancing with the stars
but one time we talked to slender about
so you think we can dance and the syttd
community like no wait so you think you
think
syt tv is say yes to the dress s-y-t
whatever why so you think you can dance
community like came for us they're like
no no we are strong so
i was wrong about that but i don't think
i'm wrong seeing as how this guy
canceled that like world of wonder dance
whatever it's called
is nothing of the sort yeah and also now
with the mask of the dancer
um how can they compete and the masked
franchise is actually like killing it
when they first announced their show
like the masked singer i'm like
well we've hit an all-time low in
creativity in hollywood like this is the
dumbest idea people [ __ ] love it
i i know you know i felt that way about
this show that they were
showing a commercial for last night on
the bachelor um it's about like
it's like a dog grooming competition
like perfect pooch or something lisa
vanderpump is a judge
rebel wilson hosts and i was like
literally who would ever watch it the
commercial comes on i'll tell you who
bruno was hyphen and it's like oh then i
would put it on if
if bruno would enjoy it no and that's
actually similar to like so you think
you can dance like there is a cult
community of people who are like
obsessed with dog grooming there's a
community of people who are obsessed
with dancing like
that's the beauty of entertainment like
there's truly
something for everyone there's dr pimple
popper her show is very popular on tlc
yeah i just i wouldn't have expected a
dog grooming show on like abc
prime time but you never know have you
watched the thousand pound sisters
i have not it's so good and they're like
viral on tick tock
and um there's this sound that's going
viral
and it's literally like me and you trap
being my
size amy you don't know
how it is it's literally like my life in
a sound
and i think you should get into thousand
pound sisters it is a spin-off of my 600
pound life which
they're a thousand pounds together oh
you know it's a little misleading and
i'm losing a thousand pounds each
because why is she saying try being my
size if they're
so i think it's like 600 and 400 like
one i forget
i forget their names but one of them is
much more um
physically like able-bodied than the
other because there's such a disparity
between their weight
oh okay that's confusing yeah but we
love a sister show and i actually think
you would like it i have to get olivia
to watch it because olivia and i
are obsessed with my 600 pound life and
literally olivia once bought me a magnet
um you're supposed to put it on your
fridge of dr desarton so like every time
you go in for a snack it's like what
would dr nazardan say
that's really funny and he's a [ __ ]
savage like that he really um is the
heart and soul of that franchise
oh for sure tlc is just popping out
weird content left and right i actually
that's
what they do i went through a tlc phase
like i was
obsessed with sister wives um which just
like recently became like it's
it's too much for me um and i also
became obsessed with um
my uh 19 pound scrotum something like
that
it was a really interesting show when i
was in high school like me and my
friends were obsessed with tlc like we
would watch you crazy as [ __ ]
that's so crazy and then like me and my
friend rachel who were like
really obsessed we both decided to start
sister wives and
she didn't start it and i did and then i
became so hooked
um and that's how my love affair with
cody robin and the gang began
damn okay maybe i'll check out
thousand-pound sisters
i actually think you'll like it like
they're hysterical oh and they're also
influencers like
they like have a community before the
show now they're super famous but before
the show they were like youtubers oh
cool
you know it's just it's very layered
which is my new favorite word i think we
need layered merch
okay i say everything is layered because
you know what most things are
thank you most things are um theo just
got up looks like he's enjoying the
carpet
yeah that's all you can hope for that's
a sign of approval for sure
i think that's it right i think that is
all she wrote on this
beautiful tuesday thank you guys so
much for listening to the morning toast
the millennial morning show where we
deliver the fast five stories that you
need to know every monday through friday
on youtube so
if you're watching this on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so it's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio iho
radio cast box all the places
so wherever you listen to podcasts find
us the morning toast and leave a five
star review about how beautiful stunning
and smart we are
we hope you have an amazing day
and we'll see you tomorrow for home day
and a little sneak peek of our new merch
launching on thursday
bye